[Música]
hola bienvenidos a 5 minutos con los
casos de kobe 19 en paraguay han ido en
aumento durante las últimas semanas este
es uno de los países con la cifra más
baja de vacunación si se compara con sus
vecinos suramericanos el manejo de la
pandemia por parte del gobierno que la
población civil ha calificado como
pésimo desencadenó una serie de
protestas que pedían la salida del
presidente mario abdo benítez pero los
intentos por destituirlo fracasaron
vamos a analizar este tema y por ello
saludamos a pedro javier cano analista
político y ex ministro de justicia y
trabajo quien se encuentra desde la
capital paraguaya pedro muy buenos días
sabemos que la situación sanitaria se ha
agudizado durante los últimos días
debido al aumento en los contagios de
kobe 19 cuéntenos cuál es el panorama de
salud en este momento en el país
sí muy buenos días a usted ya su
audiencia y efectivamente así verá se
hizo el problema a medida que van
pasando los días hay aumentos de
contagios y independientemente a eso
también se ha incrementado la cantidad
de fallecidos esto hizo que la población
por supuesto se manifestara
independientemente al tema del juicio
político la gente salió a la calle a
exigir la renuncia del presidente y el
vicepresidente lo cual fracasó
políticamente en el congreso y hoy
estamos ante la desesperación de que la
vacuna
definitivamente lleguen al país ese es
el panorama actual que tenemos ya vamos
a hablar de las vacunas pero como usted
lo mencionaba hace unas semanas hubo una
serie de protestas contra el gobierno
acusándolo del mal manejo de esta
emergencia sanitaria provocada por el
virus cuál es la situación del gobierno
hoy del gobierno de mario abdo benítez
luego del fallido intento de juicio
político
bueno el presidente se había aislado no
había hecho ningún tipo de declaración
aproximadamente por 30 días en donde
antes del fallido intento de juicio
político
hace como 23 días y finalmente dio una
conferencia de prensa en donde ha sido
muy criticado nuevamente porque no hizo
una autocrítica de su gestión más bien
se pasó alabando sus su gobierno y
prometió una vez más hacer las gestiones
para que la población finalmente acceda
a las vacunas lo cual es muy distante
porque hasta hoy día lo único que
paraguay a recibir son donación negra
las sombras que se hicieron que se
pagaron por adelantado no han llegado
han llegado en pequeñas dosis y eso es
una preocupación para toda la población
en este momento nosotros estamos con
restricciones a través de un decreto del
poder ejecutivo en donde en las ciudades
más importantes del país hay
limitaciones en cuanto al desplazamiento
en cierto horario simplemente se puede
desplazar 1 de las 5 de la mañana hasta
las 20 horas y volvieron las
restricciones digamos que sanitaria y
eso ha hecho también que las
manifestaciones disminuyeron porque han
salido con el ministerio público la
fiscalía la policía nacional arrestara
personas que se manifiestan pero porque
hay este estancamiento que usted
menciona frente al proyecto de
vacunación
bueno el principal problema que tuvo
paraguay es que fue uno de los primeros
países que digamos hizo las gestiones
para la compra a través de un sistema
que se llama kóvacs adelantó el dinero
por aproximadamente 7 millones de
dólares para tener aproximadamente 3
millones de dosis sin embargo
aparentemente nadie se percató que en el
contrato efectivamente figuraba un plazo
de entrega no en forma inmediata sino
que la gente que se comprueba que se
comprometió a hacer una entrega tienen
un plazo de hasta 2 años para su entrega
por lo tanto es poco es posible apurar
eso
pedro javier cano analista político y ex
ministro de justicia y trabajo muchas
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en france
24 y ustedes muchas gracias por
sintonizarnos los invitamos a que
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]